- Well, I saw something
you posted about sauce?
You rate things by sauce.
- Yeah.
- So, what does that mean,
and where did the
sauce-rating system come from?
- You know, it started with...
I've been obviously with my
kids a ton during this break,
and so I find myself
cooking a ton of meals.
- Yes.
- Cooking meals for kids
is such a thankless gig.
- Yeah.
They think you're like a short-order cook.
I'm like, "Yeah, I can't
just whip that up, so."
- As well as, I'll make things...
Before had kids, I just
didn't cook very much.
So, I'll make something
that is really solid,
and their response will
be after a bite, like,
"I'll take cereal instead."
And so, we started...
we've been watching a
lot of cooking shows,
- Mm hmm.
- and so my way of getting
cooking to work with my kids is
rather than they're themselves
when I present them the food,
they're the judges on a cooking show.
- Oh my gosh, you're clever!
- Well, it makes it all of a
sudden they eat the whole meal,
because they're a judge.
So, they'll say like, "I like the texture,
but I don't love the
cheese on the quesadilla,"
and I'll be like, "Thank
you, judge. How about you?"
And they'll have to take another
bite, and blah, blah, blah.
We realized in doing this game,
we didn't have enough terms,
'cause they're six, they're twins,
so, their numbers aren't great.
So, they would say like...
I would say, "Out of 10, what is it?"
And they'd be like "100 out of one."
(Kelly laughs)
No, that doesn't work.
So, we created a sauce system.
- "100 out of one."
- And so we'd be like, "All right,
so if you really like something,
it's extra sauce.
If you don't like it, the sauce was bad."
And so that's how we've been doing it.
And then, you know.
- That's the most clever...
like you should write a parenting book.
'Cause, man, my son,
my four-year-old is...
I can get my girl, my
six-year-old, to eat anything.
Especially if I bribe with
some kind of treat afterwards.
My son will stave.
He will literally look me
in the eye and go, "Nope."
- It's so tricky!
(Kelly laughs)
- Like, okay.
Anyway, so, I'm going to try this.
That's what I'm gonna do.
I don't know if he'll
get that at four yet,
but maybe by the time he's six.